[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, there.
We're in the AR and
VR tent right now.
And I'm going to play with some
of the coolest, latest stuff
from Tango and Daydream.
Want to come along?
OK.
See?
That's the Earth.
I don't know much about this,
but my friend [? Aton ?]
over there, maybe he
can come explain it.
SPEAKER 1: Hey, Timothy.
All right.
So here we are at the
Tango booth at Google I/O.
And we're going to show off a
product that we announced today
called AR Expeditions.
And this is all about
helping kids in schools
learn in a different way, in
a more immersive and intuitive
way.
So we're actually
going to bring things
to them, in front of them,
compositing virtual objects
into the real world that
enable them to just see
the sun, and the
Earth, and the moon,
and some other things too.
So Brandon over here is going
to help us out with that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Let's check it out.
BRANDON: Yeah.
So what we're looking at
here is we can actually
see the Earth that
has been placed
in our actual physical space.
So we'd map the room, we
understand where we're at.
And we can actually
allow students
to all experience
the Earth together,
and look around, and find
the five different hurricanes
that are around the Earth.
We can do things like
switch to the moon.
And you can see, actually,
the approximate location here
that Neil Armstrong landed
on the moon initially.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What?
BRANDON: Pretty awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That is so cool.
We can also see the sun.
Can we actually go
around this side?
So we can see, if we go around
this side, the different layers
inside the sun and
how hot they are.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Whoa, that is crazy.
BRANDON: Here, we can
see the inner planets.
And students can
actually go, and explore,
and see Earth and its relative
size to Mars or Venus.
We can also see other planets
like Jupiter or Saturn.
Look at that.
And then kind of my
favorite is actually
looking at the asteroid belt,
because it seems like you're
flying through the asteroids.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
BRANDON: Pretty fun.
And then finally,
on our exploration
of the solar system, you
can see dwarf planets
such as Haumea or Pluto.
And Haumea really
interesting, because it's
this kind of
smashed-looking planet,
something that would be
really hard to kind of get
a sense of if you weren't
being able to see this
placed in your physical
space and compared
to the other planets.
So that's Expeditions AR.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's Expeditions AR.
Thank you so much.
That is really cool.
I'm just going to play with
this for a little while.
You guys don't mind, do you?
BRANDON: Let's go back
to the asteroid belt,
because that one's the best one.
So you can kind of feel like
you're flying through space.
Take a look.
Whoop.
There it goes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Whoa.
BRANDON: There it is.
You feel like you're
actually flying.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And what's really
cool here is that we're all
playing in this same space
together.
BRANDON: Yeah, this is great.
Actually, there was an attendee
just earlier that was asking,
why would we want to bring
this in the classroom
and not just have them
work on their laptops?
But what's nice is instead
of being heads down
and exploring this on your own,
or kind of passively learning,
you can actually go and you can
move around the asteroid belt.
You can move around
Jupiter or Saturn.
And you can do that not just by
yourself, but with the teacher
or with the other students.
And that's really
the power of Tango--
being able to have
this shared space
and use it as this
educational tool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thank you so much.
BRANDON: Yup, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Let's go check out
some more cool stuff.
SPEAKER 1: Here, we're
showing up a partnership
with Gap where they
want to allow people
to see what clothes might
look like on mannequins,
but in their home.
So you can bring their whole
product catalog to your home.
And so what we've got here
is a bunch of options.
Maybe I'm looking for a dress.
So I drop it into the
world, select a size.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm
a size 5, actually.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Timothy.
So we've got a size
6 mannequin here.
And you can change
the size of the dress.
So you can see how an extra
small would look, a small would
look, or a medium.
But sometimes I want to see
what a medium would look
like next to an extra small.
So I can press the plus icon.
And now I have two
mannequins in space.
And you can see one of
them has a medium, which
is a little bit looser
and more drapey.
And the other one
has an extra small.
And you can get
right up in on them.
You can see the
texture of the fabric.
And they actually do a very
realistic physics simulation,
which is pretty cool too, to
get the drapiness correct.
So this is just one way to
bring shopping into your home.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
Well, can I?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
think what's really
neat is you could
sort of walk around it
like you do in a store, which
feels a lot different than just
pressing buttons on a web page.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, it gives you
a much better sense of scale
and how the garment's
actually going
to look on someone who's
roughly your body size.
So here, we have a
storytelling experience,
where we're bringing some
characters from "The Wizard
of Oz" into the space.
And we're doing
some special things.
We're really working
on showing off
how well we can composite
them into the space
and light them
relative to the space.
You'll see what I
mean in a minute.
But you can take
pictures with the Lion,
or the Scarecrow,
or the Tin Man.
And yeah, it's a really
interesting and social AR
experience.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, maybe we
can show everybody
what you see while I just
kind of stand over there.
SPEAKER 1: Sure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Here, let me hand
you the microphone.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
All right.
So here, we can have you take
a picture with a character.
So here, you're kind
of behind the Lion.
You can stand next to him.
We can see that
the Lion is here.
And so now I will
take a picture.
Ready?
Smile.
Yeah, do a flex.
Nice.
That's a good picture.
Cool.
So we've got a few pictures
of you with the friendly Lion.
So this is kind of what the
intro experience looks like.
So if you want, you
can even hold it.
And you can kind of look around.
And you'll just get taken
through each character.
So the mode we used earlier was
just so you could take selfies.
But this actually shows the
characters doing something.
You can see he's writing
on the actual wall there.
So that's the kind
of registration
that we have to the environment
in this scene, which
is really great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: (LAUGHING)
Oh-oh, poor Toto.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
tornadoes are unfortunate.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
All right.
Well, I think we have one more
Tango experience to check out.
VIVEK: How are you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm good.
How are you, Vivek?
VIVEK: I'm good too.
Thanks.
So here, I'm going to
demonstrate the Constructor
app.
It's built on the
hardware and software
stack provided by Tango.
So this is one of our new phones
that is being released by ASIS.
It's coming around this summer.
So as you know,
the Tango phones,
they have a depth sensor for
sensing the 3D environment.
It has a fisheye camera,
which is used for tracking
and that, in combination, we
are able to accurately get
the 3D position of the
phone as you move around.
And so let me demonstrate
one of the apps
that we have created
for this purpose.
So what we are seeing
right now is the raw output
of the depth camera.
And as you move around, you can
sort of make out the objects.
But what it's basically doing
is that each pixel is not
a color value,
but rather how far
that particular object
that you're seeing
is from the camera.
And we have this
recording mode, where,
once we start
recording, what it does
is it takes all of these depth
images and it combines them.
So sort of like stitching them
together into the 3D space
to create a mesh.
And you can sort of walk around
and painting the surfaces.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
That was very easy.
VIVEK: Yeah, it's as easy
as using a regular camera.
And once you stop
the recording, it'll
do a little bit of processing.
And then what you have is the
3D mesh of the environment
that you just scanned.
So you can imagine, if you
spend a little bit more time,
let's say 10 minutes
or so, comprehensively
scanning the
environment, then you can
get much more better models.
And I'll show you an example
of some of the models
that we have created before.
So here's a
two-bedroom apartment
that was scanned in
about 15 to 20 minutes.
Just walk around using the
same process that we just
did for a few seconds.
And voila.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
is really cool, Vivek.
VIVEK: Yeah, that's
pretty exciting stuff.
So let's look at another
model that we scan.
We can also use this for
scanning outdoor environments.
So now, remember that
the depth camera works
using IR light, infrared light.
And since there is a lot
of ambient infrared light
in bright sunlight, that
would interfere with it.
But if it's a
cloudy day, then you
can reasonably scan
outdoor environments.
And here is somebody who scanned
the outside of their house.
And you can see they did a
really good job in scanning it.
And the result is
also quite impressive.
Since this phone is also
a Daydream-ready phone,
we have this
Daydream button here.
So once you click on
that, you can pair it
and put it in one of
these Daydream headsets
and look at these things in VR.
That's, in a nutshell,
what our app can do.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's perfect.
Thank you so much.
VIVEK: Oh, you're quite welcome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So we're going to go check
out some Daydream here.
We're here in the AR
and VR Tent still.
And now we're going
to look at Daydream.
I'm here with Brian.
Brian, how are you doing?
BRIAN: Hey, I'm doing excellent.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
you're going to help
me experience some Daydream.
BRIAN: Yeah.
That's absolutely right.
So Daydream, it's our mobile
virtual reality platform.
What we're going to be looking
at is virtual virtual reality.
It's the experience
that Clay talked
about during the keynote,
where you go further
and further into VR from inside
VR just like "Inception."
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
I've got to try this.
BRIAN: It's pretty rad.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So all I need to do is
put on the headset, right?
BRIAN: Yup.
So I'll get you set up here.
And in just a moment, you'll
be going into VR inside of VR.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Now, while you're
setting that up,
Brian's actually going to grab
his phone, and outside the kind
of headset experience
to give you
an idea of what it
feels like or what I'm
experiencing with the headset.
Sound good?
All right.
BRIAN: There you go.
And here's your
Daydream controller.
SPEAKER 2 (ON SCREEN): Oh, wow.
[CHUCKLES] While I appreciate
your selection, I must insist
you choose one of the
three test objects.
Now pick it up and
stick it to me.
[GROAN] Perfectly crunchy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That was really fun.
BRIAN: How'd you like it?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
a little strange.
The content of it--
it was strange.
BRIAN: If you
butter toast in VR,
you butter toast in real life.
That's how it works.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's how it works?
And all the headset--
I'm sorry, what were you saying?
BRIAN: I was just saying if
you butter toast in real life,
you butter toast in VR.
It's all confusing.
Nobody knows what it means.
It's crazy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, and the
headsets just kept coming.
And you went deeper
and deeper into VR.
BRIAN: Exactly.
Yeah.
The actual experience is
about two to three hours long.
And you just continue
going further and further
into virtual reality.
There's a couple
different things
that are going on here,
where, at the very beginning,
you choose between a potted
plant, a fish, and a ball.
And no matter what choice you
make, you're always wrong.
So it's part of that
illusion of choice
that virtual reality can give
you and a lot of the things
that the game designers
chose to do to give you
that illusion of choice.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
There was a lot of fun, Brian.
Thank you so much.
BRIAN: Yeah, thanks so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]